[Music]
guest is that comedian who could be seen
hosting his live podcast the anytime
show every Saturday at the little modern
theatre right here in Los Angeles please
welcome the very funny Dominick Dierkes
oh thank you guys so much it's a
pleasure to be here I'll start off by
telling you a little bit about myself I
am alarmingly skinny I know this is the
case because when I tell people how much
I weigh they have a very specific
reaction I like because I'm 6 1 I weigh
about 150 pounds and when I tell people
that people are already oh when I tell
people that this I've gotten this exact
reaction several different times in that
reaction is 150 pounds oof you would not
do well in prison and that's not fair I
don't think that's now don't get me
wrong I don't think I would do well in
prison that's not what I'm saying at all
but I think that has far less to do with
my weight and far more to do with my
feminine features and eagerness to
please
I don't think it's fair because I don't
see those st. people going up to fat
folks like how much you weigh 300 pounds
you know you should go to prison you
ever think about it it's a weight based
institution you thrive I'm terrible at
remembering people's names it's a real
like character flaw of mine where I'll
just meet someone like 10 or 12 times
and I just can't keep their name in my
head and when you're like me it's very
rude to just keep asking someone their
name you can't do that so you have to do
what I do which is the polite thing
which is trick them into telling you
what their name is right this is my
favorite trick feel free to use this I
always go you don't be hilarious is if
we looked at each other's driver's
license photos mine so embarrassing
let's see yours pal and then they're
always like pal you don't know my name
do you and that's when I chloroformed
them I dragged him down to my base when
I keep him there for a little while you
know a couple weeks ago by my buddies
start coming around hey man we're
getting kind of worried have you seen
Cory I'm like Cory
[Applause]
I one of my favorite pastimes is judging
people based on slogans they have
written on their t-shirts I think that's
a very fun thing to do because people
people that have slogans out and they're
disingenuous a lot of the time they're
not really like I saw a woman walking
down the street with a t-shirt that was
way too tight and the t-shirt just said
too much princess for just one man yeah
I doubt it you know I doubt that's the
problem there I doubt when her boyfriend
broke up with her he's like I'm sorry I
am but one man you are far too much
princess I wish there were more men
around for all the princess you are it's
not a truthful shirt oh I think a more
truthful version of that shirt would be
too much [ __ ] for just one everybody
[Music]
I spent far too much time on Facebook I
don't know if you guys have the same
problem where I'm just on Facebook
clicking on ex-girlfriends profiles just
just like I went to I went out with you
and this is your house and family now
and some people call that stalking but I
don't think that's fair I think we use
that word far too much when talking
about Facebook because like it's not
stalking you hear people all the time
like oh I stopped this guy by going to
his publicly available profile and
stalking him that's not stalking that
kind of talk must piss off real stalkers
you know like real pre-internet
salt-of-the-earth stalkers just like
stalking stop being in front of a
computer Stalkings being in a van oh she
had a Foursquare check-in at a Starbucks
good for you and my day we had to go to
all the Starbucks
[Applause]
there is no Google Maps there's no
Street View this might not be her house
that's part of it
[Laughter]
I spend a lot of time online looking at
technology - I love technology my
favorite piece of technology you might
have heard about this is the Google car
I love you yeah there you go it's a car
that drives by itself in traffic doesn't
need human interference so you can just
be in the car texting while it's like we
do anyway but this way won't be insanely
dangerous which is the problem the way
we drive is insane like when we tell our
grandkids who all have Google cars how
we used to drive they're going to think
we were the craziest generation of
maniacs to ever live they're gonna be
like grandpa you mean the car didn't
park for you how'd you do it oh I just
kind of eyeball it just give a quick
glance and go that seemed correct and
then just wing the big machine in there
what grandpa did you hit stuff oh yeah
good god I was always hitting stuff come
on
a lot of times I didn't look back to see
what it was cuz you know I can't live
with that
what's grandpa did people die oh it was
the number one way to die for years
[Applause]
Dominic target
[Applause]